On June 26 2020 the US House of
Representatives voted to do something it
had never done before it passed a bill
to create the 51st state by giving the
US Capitol washington DC statehood
members of the House of Representatives
each represent between 500,000 and a
million Americans DC 700,000 residents
are represented by this woman
eleanor holmes norton but she couldn't
vote on the statehood bill because she's
different from other members she can
speak on the floor and introduce bills
but she can actually vote americans and
territories like Puerto Rico and Guam
are also represented in Congress by
delegates who can't vote but Americans
in these places don't pay federal taxes
to the US government DC residents do in
fact in DC the average person pays more
in federal taxes than in any state and
they're not happy about it it's why DC's
license plates say taxation without
representation precedent Trump has
promised to block Washington DC from
becoming the state so that House vote
was mostly symbolic but Washington DC's
residents are clear on what they want so
will DC ever actually become a state and
should it
in the US the federal government is not
supposed to be based in a state the
Constitution says it should be in a
neutral federal district what today is
called the District of Columbia but
since the founding of the country the
district has grown into a major city for
most of its existence as a city the
district has been under the control of
the United States Congress starting in
the 1960s Congress made some concessions
to DC's calls for representation it
granted them electoral college votes for
presidential elections a non-voting
member in Congress and finally the right
to elect their own local government but
because Congress still completely
controls their budget they often
undermine DC's local government which is
another major reason DC residents want
statehood that's understating it a
little in the 2016 election Trump only
got a whopping 4% of the vote in DC
Congress has kept DC from using their
local tax dollars on things like
abortion services or needle exchange
programs to reduce hiv/aids they've
tried to undercut DC's gun laws and
same-sex marriage benefits and they
stopped the city from legalizing
marijuana as a prop Holmes Norton's plan
would turn most of the District of
Columbia into a new state called the
Douglas Commonwealth there would still
be a federal district around the actual
government buildings but the remaining
66 square miles of neighborhoods would
become the newest smallest state but it
would still have a larger population
than two states and would be about the
same size as for others so what's the
holdup
well representatives from other states
have lots of reasons founding fathers
did not intend for Washington DC to be a
state Washington DC is a city not a
state there is no manufacturing there is
no mining or law
but it's not a coincidence that every
representative speaking out against
statehood here is Republicans statehood
would give DC and most likely the
Democratic Party one more vote in the
House of Representatives and two more
votes in the Senate which means the
actual obstacle to statehood is politics
in the decades after the US was founded
new states were regularly added and
without much issue until 1818 when
Missouri wanted to become a new state at
that time power in Congress was evenly
balanced between states that allowed
slavery and states that didn't Missouri
which would become a slave state would
tip that balance which representatives
of the free states didn't want so
Congress came up with a compromise
Missouri would be added at the same time
as Maine a free state a pair to keep the
political balance after that states were
mostly added in pairs Arkansas a slave
state with Michigan a free state Florida
a slave state with Iowa a free state
Texas
a slave state with Wisconsin a free
state and that system has also been used
to keep the balance between the
political parties most recently in 1959
with the addition of Hawaii which leaned
Republican at the time and Alaska which
leaned Democratic right now Democrats
control one house of Congress but
Republicans control the other one as
well as the presidency and as long as
that's the case DC is unlikely to become
a state on its own it would certainly be
easier if there were some ready
jurisdiction to be made to stay that was
a Republican jurisdiction the last time
the House voted on DC statehood was in
1993 when Democrats had an even bigger
majority than they do today
the bill still failed with more than a
hundred Democrats voting No
2020 is turning out to be different
rotavirus begins to take a toll on the
US economy more than six million
Americans filed jobless claims in March
as millions lost their jobs Congress
passed a coronavirus relief bill giving
each state at least a billion dollars
but DC which is usually treated like a
state and most congressional funding was
instead treated as a u.s. territory and
got less than half that being treated
like a territory is shocking it's
infuriating in June as protests against
police violence spread across the
country the National Guard patrolled
parts of the city that kind of
occupation would be illegal in every
state but not DC there shouldn't be
troops from other states in Washington
DC in the last several days demonstrate
that our fight for statehood is also
about our right to autonomy it's time
for statehood to come to Washington DC
we've seen in very painful and frankly
violent terms what the lack of statehood
can bring to the residents of the
District of Columbia right now the
people in charge of the federal
government opposed DC statehood but it
only takes one election to change that
[Music]
Americans in the DC fire department his
father Richard Holmes was a runaway
slave from Virginia
he walked to freedom but he he didn't
walk to equality so I figure I'm picking
up where he left off he got us to
freedom he got the homes family to
freedom now I've got to get the homes
family and all my constituents to
equality
[Music]